Here's an example.
Imagine your network is
a stack of simple operations.
Like in your transforms,
whatever you want.
Some have parameters like the matrix
transforms, some don't like the rellers.
When you apply your
data to some input x,
you have data flowing through
the stack up to your predictions y.
To compute the derivatives, you create
another graph that looks like this.
The data in the new graph flows
backwards through the network,
get's combined using the chain rule that
we saw before and produces gradients.
That graph can be derived completely
automatically from the individual
operations in your network.
So most deep learning frameworks
will just do it for you.
This is called back-propagation,
and it's a very powerful concept.
It makes computing derivatives of
complex function very efficient
as long as the function is made up of
simple blocks with simple derivatives.
Running the model up to the predictions
is often call the forward prop, and
the model that goes backwards
is called the back prop.
So, to recap,
to run stochastic gradient descent,
for every single little batch of
your data in your training set,
you're going to run the forward prop,
and then the back prop.
And that will give you gradients for
each of your weights in your model.
Then you're going to apply those
gradients with the learning weights
to your original weights,
and update them.
And you're going to repeat that
all over again, many, many times.
This is how your entire
model gets optimized.
I am not going to go through more
of the maths of what's going on in
each of those blocks.
Because, again, you don't typically
have to worry about that, and
it's essentially the chain rule,
but keep in mind, this diagram.
In particular each block of
the back prop often takes about
twice the memory that's needed for
prop and twice the compute.
That's important when you
want to size your model and
fit it in memory for example.